el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden aseguró haber tomado ya la
decisión de postularse para un segundo
mandato al terminar su gira por Irlanda
y sin dar más detalles el jefe de la
Casa Blanca dijo que anunciaría su
campaña relativamente pronto
la inflación de tres dígitos en
Argentina no ha llegado a su pico en
marzo los precios subieron 104,3%
interanual casi dos puntos más de lo
registrado en febrero educación prendas
de vestir y alimentos o lo que más sube
protestas en diferentes ciudades de
Francia después de la decisión del
Consejo constitucional que aprobó los
puntos clave de la impopular Reforma
pensional la edad de jubilación pasará
de 62 a 64 años se espera la pronta
promulgación de la medida por parte de
Manuel macron los sindicatos aseguran
que la lucha se mantiene
Bienvenidos a este resumen Informativo
en Francia 24 los acompaña Daniel
hablando comenzamos en Estados Unidos
porque el presidente Joe biden dijo este
viernes que ya ha tomado la decisión de
postularse para un segundo mandato y que
anunciaría su campaña relativamente
pronto lo hizo al terminar su visita
oficial de 4 días a Irlanda en donde
unas 27.000 personas lo ovacionaron
mientras de vuelta a casa sus índices de
popularidad están en los niveles más
bajos desde que comenzó su mandato el
jefe de la Casa Blanca ha mostrado
durante mucho tiempo su intención de
lanzarse a la reelección pero la falta
de un anuncio formal ha sembrado
incertidumbre entre quienes cuestionan
que pueda salir victorioso de nuevo si
se vuelve a enfrentar en las urnas con
el expresidente republicano Donald Trump
quien ya lanzó su campaña
puede decirnos en los últimos días ha
cambiado su cálculo sobre cuándo hará un
anuncio sobre su plan para campaña
presidencial no no no no ya hice ese
cálculo lo anunciaremos relativamente
pronto pero el viaje aquí reforzó mi
sentido de optimismo sobre lo que se
puede hacer
así que ha tomado una decisión sólo
tiene que anunciarla te lo dije mi plan
es volver a postularme
y el presidente biden también se
pronunció sobre el escándalo de
filtraciones de documentos clasificados
del pentágono que ha dejado a Estados
Unidos en medio de una tormenta
diplomática el mandatario aseguró que
pidió a su gobierno averiguar por qué el
sospechoso de publicar los documentos
tuvo acceso a tanta información
jactexeira compareció por primera vez
ante un tribunal Federal fue imputado
por dos delitos de los que se declaró No
culpable el informe es de Samuel Salgado
sospechoso de ocasionar el peor
escándalo de la última década en materia
de filtraciones de documentos secretos
en Estados Unidos compareció por primera
vez ante un tribunal de Boston texeira
Fue capturado por el FBI y el jueves y
es acusado de retención y transmisión no
autorizada de información de defensa
nacional en virtud de la ley de
espionaje tanto el departamento de
Justicia como el pentágono son enfáticos
en señalar la gravedad del escándalo de
filtración
no se trata solo de llevarse documentos
a casa eso es por supuesto ilegal en sí
mismo se trata de la transmisión tanto
de la retención ilegal como de la
transmisión de los documentos todo el
mundo sabe aquí que los documentos al
final fueron transmitidos
este fue un acto criminal deliberado una
violación de las pautas creo que es
importante entenderlo
un joven empleado de la guardia Nacional
de las aéreas Se declaró No culpable
pero permanecerá bajo arresto en la
espera de juicio la audiencia de tensión
está prevista para el 19 de abril si es
hallado culpable podría enfrentar 15
años de prisión los documentos filtrados
Aparentemente por teixeira se cuentan en
más de 100 y revelan principalmente
información estratégicas sobre la guerra
en Ucrania también evidencian espionaje
estadounidense algunos de sus
importantes aliados como Corea del Sur y
circularon en redes sociales durante
varios días antes de que las autoridades
estadounidenses se percataran
y en ese mismo país la Corte Suprema
mantiene temporalmente el acceso sin
restricciones a la píldora abortiva
mifepristona la decisión llega tras las
restricciones impuestas previamente por
una corte de apelaciones que entrarían
en vigencia el fin de semana los
detalles de la noticia con nuestro
corresponsal y Washington en Cristobal
Vázquez
la Corte Suprema de Justicia restauró
temporalmente el acceso total a la
píldora abortiva Mr pistone suspendiendo
la decisión de un tribunal inferior de
Texas que dejaba sin piso la aprobación
del gobierno de la píldora abortiva
utilizada en más de la mitad de los
abortos en Estados Unidos El juez Samuel
alito accedió a la solicitud del
gobierno de restaurar hasta el miércoles
de la próxima semana el acceso total a
la píldora y solicitó además información
adicional para el próximo martes
concretamente el gobierno de biden y El
fabricante de medicamentos dannco
laboratories instaron a la corte a no
cuestionar la experiencia de la
administración de drogas y alimentos de
Estados Unidos fda que se basó en datos
de docenas de ensayos clínicos cuando
aprobó la mifepristone hace 23 años y
que ahora un juez nombrado por Trump
está cuestionando según el gobierno
dejar el fallo del juez de Texas en su
lugar crearía confusión e incertidumbre
para los proveedores de servicios de
aborto y tendría consecuencias
devastadoras para la capacidad de la
industria farmacéutica y para que esta
industria pueda llevar nuevos
medicamentos al mercado la Corte Suprema
también podría reprogramar rápidamente
una sesión informativa completa y un
argumento oral para revisar el caso
antes del receso de verano de la corte
y el estado de Montana está a un paso de
convertirse en el primero de Estados
Unidos en prohibir completamente el uso
de la red social tiktok con una votación
de 54 contra 43 en la cámara de
representantes dio la aprobación final
al proyecto conocido como sb419 que
prohibiría a las tiendas de aplicaciones
ofrecer la descarga de tiktok a los
usuarios de Montana esta medida va más
allá de las prohibiciones ya
establecidas por el Gobierno Federal
sobre la descarga de tiktok en
dispositivos de propiedad pública el
proyecto ahora pasa a consideración del
gobernador republicano Greg jeanford
para convertirse en ley mientras que
tiktok denuncia una violación a la
primera enmienda de la Constitución y
advierte que el asunto se decantará en
las Cortes
en Argentina del Instituto Nacional de
estadísticas y censos dio a conocer que
en el mes de marzo los ciudadanos
experimentaron una inflación del 104,3%
interanual este hecho aumenta el
descontento ante la gestión del
presidente Alberto Fernández de Cara a
las elecciones presidenciales del
próximo 22 de octubre Rafael Pérez nos
cuenta más
es el azote de la economía Argentina en
el mes de marzo la nación suramericana
registró la inflación más alta de los
últimos 12 meses según el Instituto
Nacional de estadísticas y censo indec
el aumento de los precios a los
consumidores se ubicó en un
104,3%, este fenómeno económico al que
el estado no ha sabido dar respuesta
golpea constantemente el bolsillo de los
argentinos puedo hacerlo a las compras
de supermercado y semanalmente me van
aumentando las cosas semanalmente es
decir y en una proporción a veces en los
alimentos del 10 al 15% caso del queso
Pues sería la carne la carne me pasó en
un año de
1.200 pesos a 2.800 cerca del 40% de los
ciudadanos vive la pobreza según el
indec Un aumento que se ha vivido en los
últimos años en parte bajo el gobierno
peronista tratando de pensar que en
algún momento vamos a poder estar mejor
tenemos un país como para poder estar
mejor pero bueno Lamentablemente nos
administran de una manera muy mala la
noción suramericana también vive una de
las peores sequías de su historia lo que
la imposibilita exportar miles de
millones de dólares en productos
agrícolas esto además incrementa el
valor de granos como el trigo y el maíz
dentro de sus fronteras yo creo que en
primera instancia lo que bajas lo que
bajas es la calidad del producto sí
porque lo que antes capaz consumía de un
poco mejor Hoy está como si siempre fue
claro siempre fue cinco seis no sé 10
pesos más hoy son 100 pesos más y en el
global al cierre que vos haces la compra
del mes es como su montones mucha la
diferencia la inflación hace Mella en la
popularidad del presidente Alberto
Fernández de Cara a las próximas
elecciones presidenciales de octubre
según la agencia de noticias raiters un
poco más del 20% de los argentinos
aprueba su gestión donde la economía y
los enfrentamientos internos en el
peronismo han sido su punto más débil
y a noticias de Europa en Francia el
aumento de la edad de jubilación de 62 a
64 años ya tiene luz verde el consejo
constitucional dio el visto bueno a las
partes esenciales del impopular proyecto
de Emmanuel macron y rechazó la
convocatoria a un referendo solicitado
por la oposición la decisión desató
protestas en varias ciudades de Francia
los detalles los tiene más Romero sola
una vez más las manifestaciones llenaron
las calles de las ciudades francesas en
contra de la Reforma pensional de Manuel
macron en León y por supuesto París la
coalición de ocho sindicatos convocó
protestas para rechazar la aprobación
definitiva del Consejo constitucional de
este proyecto de ley que sube la edad de
jubilación de los 82 a los 64 años y que
alrededor del 70% de los franceses
desaprueba
los sindicatos anunciaron que las
movilizaciones se mantendrán
no se puede gobernar un país contra su
pueblo Emmanuel macron no puede seguir
dirigiendo el país si no retira esta
reforma para permitir la calma y
reencontrar la vía del diálogo
la oposición política también se
pronunció tanto desde la izquierda como
desde la derecha
la decisión del Consejo constitucional
demuestra que está más atento a las
necesidades de la monarquía presidencial
que a las del pueblo soberano la lucha
continúa y debe reunir sus fuerzas si la
decisión del Consejo constitucional
cierra la secuencia institucional el
destino político de la Reforma de las
pensiones no está sentenciado el pueblo
aún tiene la última palabra le
corresponderá preparar una alternativa
que revierta esta reforma inútil e
injusta
sin embargo el gobierno defiende que no
hay más que hablar
el consejo constitucional ha juzgado la
reforma conforme a nuestra Constitución
tanto en el fondo como en el
procedimiento el texto ha llegado al
final de su proceso democrático esta
tarde no hay ganadores ni perdedores
la decisión de la corte elimina algunos
artículos de la propuesta de ley pero
avala su esencia Elevar la edad de
jubilación para evitar que el sistema de
pensiones sea deficitario y cierra la
puerta que se convoque un referendo para
consultar el texto con la población una
vía que la oposición quería abrir Se
espera que el gobierno de macron
promulgue la ley este mismo fin de
semana
y en otras noticias este viernes inició
en yemen una operación masiva de
intercambio de prisioneros mientras
Arabia Saudita trata de mediar entre el
gobierno y Los Rebeldes sutiles para
lograr una tregua en un país devastado
por la guerra la última operación de
este tipo se remonta a octubre de 2020
cuando más de 1000 prisioneros fueron
liberados en 48 horas
vuelven a sanar libres detenidos durante
años por el gobierno respaldado por
Arabia Saudita estos antiguos
prisioneros luchaban con Los rebeldes
sutiles apoyados por Irán
Al otro lado del asfalto las familias
destrozadas por la guerra esperan con
impaciencia el regreso de sus seres
queridos
llevamos mucho tiempo esperando este
momento lo he extrañado tanto que estoy
deseando volver a verlo
al mismo tiempo miembros del gobierno y
de la coalición militar liderada por
Arabia Saudita llegaban a adén estaban
siendo retenidos por los sutiles entre
ellos el ex ministro de defensa mahamut
al subaijí coordinado por el comité
Internacional de la Cruz Roja ese
intercambio Está programado para durar
tres días participan cerca de 900
prisioneros su Liberación se produce
tras el acuerdo alcanzado a finales de
marzo en Suiza entre el gobierno
reconocido por la comunidad
internacional y Los Rebeldes un acuerdo
firmado tras el inesperado acercamiento
entre Arabia Saudita e Irán los grandes
rivales que chocan a veces en bandos
Opuestos como en yemen
esta semana una delegación Saudita fue
asaná Se marchó el jueves con un acuerdo
preliminar sobre una tregua y la promesa
de nuevas conversaciones
Esto hace albergar esperanzas de que se
calme la situación en este país donde la
guerra ha provocado una de las peores
crisis humanitarias del mundo con
cientos de miles de muertos y millones
de desplazados
y terminamos con noticias para Los
Amantes del rock este viernes la icónica
banda metálica lanzó su décimo primer
disco titulado seventy seasons el nuevo
trabajo
el nuevo trabajo discográfico de la
agrupación californiana consta de 12
canciones líricamente densas que
referencian los primeros 18 años de la
vida del cantante
jamesfield que tocan temas como la
depresión el suicidio y la búsqueda de
la luz el disco incluye inamorata el
primer tema de más de 10 minutos de
duración en la historia de Metallica
con música Nos despedimos en France 24 a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía quédense
con nosotros
[Música]